das ist wirklich eine düster prognose
mit einem funken hoffnung die eu ziele
zum klimaschutz scheinen immer
unerreichbarer jetzt zeigt eine studie
dass sie nur noch unter der
voraussetzung zu schaffen sind das css
zum einsatz kommt also carbon capture
and storage das ist die entnahme von
kohlendioxid aus der atmosphäre und die
anschließende speicherung des co2 aber
wie funktioniert das
es gibt eine ganze reihe von verfahren
aber die haben vor und nachteile aber
ohne sie würden wir ein klimaneutrales
europa bis zum jahr 2050 wohl kaum
schaffen krieg zum science in future los
geht's herzlich willkommen klicks ums
haus im future ist teil der
bildungsinitiative vom friedrichshof
user unter dem hashtag wir bilden
zukunft findet ihr weitere spannende
inhalte hierunter me geht es übrigens
direkt zum kanal von friday is for
future mit zahlreichen videos unbedingt
abonnieren wer es noch nicht getan hat
im dezember 2015 haben sich 195 länder
auf ein allgemeines rechtsverbindliches
und weltweites klimaschutz über
einkommen geeinigt das war das ergebnis
der pariser weltklimakonferenz die der
längst überfälligen nachfolger des kyoto
protokolls von 1997 war und als großer
durchbruch gefeiert wurde
der damalige us präsident barack obama
sprach sogar von einem möglichen zitat
wendepunkt für die welt die fast 200
länder hatten sich darauf geeinigt den
durch treibhausgase verursachten anstieg
der weltweiten durchschnittstemperatur
auf deutlich unter zwei grad im
vergleich zur vorindustriellen zeit zu
begrenzen es wurde das 1,5 grad ziel
festgelegt da es die risiken und folgen
des klimawandels deutlich vermindern
würde innerhalb dieses ziels ist das
langfristige ziel der eu ein
klimaneutrales europa bis zum jahr 2050
aber um die treibhausgas neutralität
tatsächlich zu erreichen braucht es
drastische maßnahmen das zeigt jetzt die
studie unkonventioneller klimaschutz der
stiftung wissenschaft und politik deren
ergebnissen zufolge reichen
konventionelle klimaschutzmaßnahmen die
auf die vermeidung von emissionen
abziehen wie zb erneuerbare energie
oder eine optimierte energieeffizienz
nicht aus um das ziel zu schaffen das
ist laut der autoren vergeben und felix
schmid nur noch möglich wenn hunderte
millionen tonnen kohlendioxid aus der
atmosphäre entfernt also abgeschieden
und gespeichert werden damit die rest
emissionen aus dem luftverkehr der
stahl- und zementindustrie sowie der
landwirtschaft ausgeglichen werden
können muss also co2 in riesigen mengen
aus der atmosphäre entnommen werden und
das wäre eine vollkommen neue
marschrichtung in sachen klimaschutz
denn damit geht die menschheit einen
entscheidenden schritt und der ist
wahrscheinlich wirklich nicht mehr
aufzuhalten beginnt die menschheit
nämlich mit der aktiven entnahme von co2
wird sie damit dann in zukunft zur
erschaffung des klimas gelingt diese
herkulesaufgabe werden in zukunft doch
ganz andere unglaubliche dinge möglich
doch wie fängt man das an wie ist es
überhaupt möglich kohlendioxid aus der
atmosphäre zu holen es gibt eine ganze
reihe von technologien und auch
natürliche wege allerdings ist das
ziemlich tricky denn die meisten davon
sind noch nicht ausgereift und bringen
wiederum andere probleme mit sich erste
option auf fast und bäume betreiben wir
alle grünen pflanzen photosynthese dabei
findet über ihre blätter einen
gasaustausch mit der atmosphäre statt
bei dem die bäume kohlendioxid aus der
atmosphäre aufnehmen
das verarbeiten sie dann mit hilfe von
lichtenergie zu zucker den nutzen bäume
als energielieferanten für
stoffwechselprozesse beim wachstum das
kohlendioxid wird so umgewandelt zu
blättern zweigen stilen blüten holz usw
bei diesen komplexen prozess entsteht
als abfallprodukt sauerstoff der
freigesetzt wird und uns dann zum atmen
zur verfügung steht da bäume sozusagen
die luft von kohlenstoffdioxid reinigen
gilt die auffassung also das weltweite
pflanzen von bäumen als eine der
wirksamsten methoden das co2 problem in
den griff zu bekommen und wir menschen
wissen wie das geht und haben damit eine
menge erfahrung und sie hat weitere sehr
positive effekte denn mit neuen
waldflächen wird auch der natürliche
lebensraum für tiere und andere pflanzen
vergrößert noch im letzten jahr kam eine
studie der eth zürich zu dem schluss
dass das klima ziel die erderwärmung auf
1,5 grad zu begrenzen mit hilfe einer
globalen aufforstung erreichbar sei dazu
müsste aber eine
milliarde hektar land neu mit bäumen
bepflanzt werden
denn die bäume brauchen viel platz und
das dauerhaft diese fläche entspricht
etwa der fläche der gesamten usa und
zudem geraten wälder durch die höheren
temperaturen immer mehr in klima stress
und können das co2 nicht mehr dauerhaft
halten sondern geben es ab zum beispiel
durch waldbrände und da die umsetzung
zudem nicht so ganz einfach ist ich
meine die ganzen usa werden also weitere
optionen gebraucht und das sind
technologische möglichkeiten eine davon
ist die versteinerung von
kohlenstoffdioxid das projekt karpf xt
ist eine gemeinschaftsarbeit der
universität island des schweizer
unternehmens klein works das übrigens
ein start up von zwei deutschen
ingenieuren ist und dass
energieversorger trägt peak energy und
das projekt hat eine weltweit
einzigartige anlage auf der isländischen
hochebene headley sehr wie erbaut darin
wird kohlendioxid aus der umgebungsluft
gefiltert und mit wasser vermengt das
dann in 100 meter tiefe gepumpt wird
dort mineralisierten die gase im gestein
und werden dauerhaft gespeichert
allerdings verbraucht die anlage noch
sehr viel energie und das aufwendige
verfahren ist recht teuer außerdem
bekommt es bisher nur ein paar dutzend
tonnen co2 unter der erde
aber es sind bereits deutlich größere
anlagen in planung die jährlich bis zu
3000 tonnen co2 an lagern sollen
fachleute setzen große hoffnung in
solche anlagen aber 3000 tonnen pro jahr
sind immer noch nur ein bruchteil der
globalen jährlichen co2 emissionen von
rund 37 milliarden tonnen eine weitere
technologie ist es bio energie zu
produzieren und co2 unter die erde zu
leiten bio energy group carbon capture
and storage kurz ccs ist ein verfahren
bei dem biomasse in kraftwerken zu strom
verteuert und in fabriken zu treibstoff
umgewandelt wird bei der verbrennung
oder gärung entsteht kohlendioxid das
abgeschieden und unter die erde geleitet
wird die so produzierte energie kann
genutzt werden und die
treibhausgasbilanz ist trotzdem negativ
weil die pflanzen zuvor der umwelt co2
entnommen haben also biomasse ist ja
nichts anderes als pflanzen bäume und so
weiter aber auch hier gibt es einige
nachteile
so wird eine gewaltige fläche an
das land benötigt um die pflanzen
anzubauen möchte man eine einsparung von
3,3 milliarden tonnen co2 im jahr
erreichen werden dafür drei bis sieben
millionen quadratkilometern benötigt um
die entsprechende menge an
energiepflanzen anzubauen das ist noch
mal etwa ein fünftel der heutigen
globalen ackerflächen
außerdem werden die benötigten
wassermenge immens und es gebe einen
enormen verbrauchern düngemitteln dazu
kommt dass die großen unterirdischen
lagerstätten für das co2 schwer
durchsetzbar sind und auf politischen
widerstand stoßen
besonders hierzulande wo der bundesrat
einen groß angelegten test für eine
solche speicherung schon vor jahren
unterbunden hat letztlich also kaum
praktikabel
auch die nächste technik ist nicht
perfekt hat aber enormes potenzial
es gibt bestimmte gesteine wie basalt
oder du net die co2 binden wenn sie
verwittern diesen prozess möchten
forschende beschleunigen indem sie das
gestein zu pulver malen und weiträumig
verstreuen so könnten theoretisch allein
durch mineralien pulver jährlich an die
fünf milliarden tonnen kohlendioxid
gebunden werden aber eben nur
theoretisch denn um das zu schaffen
müsste über das dreifache der aktuellen
menge basalt gefördert werden und nicht
nur das es bräuchte einen massiven
energieeinsatz um es zu zermahlen über
die ganze welt zu transportieren und
schließlich zu verteilen
wegen der hohen kosten kann die
witterungs beschleunigung also nur einen
kleineren zusätzlichen beitrag leisten
aber es gibt auch eine sehr naheliegende
lösung co2 aus der luft zu filtern das
start-up klein wirksamer gerade schon
berichtet hat dafür kollektoren
entwickelt die co2 aus der aufgetauten
umgebungsluft filtern die luft strömt
durch einen zellulose filter das wird
zellulose wird wie papier aus holz
gewonnen der mit aminen getränktes das
sind chemische stoffe die das co2 binden
diese filter könnte man überall auf der
welt aufstellen und sie sind pro
quadratmeter benötigte fläche
effizienter als bäume aber auch diese
anlagen bräuchten energie in großen
mengen und das macht den prozess sehr
teuer eine tonne co2 würde
dementsprechend mindestens 500 euro
kosten das ist wirklich eine menge
außerdem bleibt die frage wohin mit dem
kohlenstoffdioxid eine unterirdische
einlagerung birgt konflikte und wenn man
daraus synthetischen treibt
dort gewinnt gelangt das klimagas ja
wieder zurück in die atmosphäre also
weiter im text
eine weitere methode könnten die
landwirte weltweit einsetzen um die
klimabilanz der landwirtschaft zu
verbessern
wenn in großem maßstab auf das umpflügen
von feldern verzichtet und der
ackerboden für die aussaat nur angeritzt
würde könnte sich humus in der obersten
bodenschicht anreichern und mehr
kohlenstoff speichern positive
nebeneffekte sind dabei das weniger
kraftstoff durch traktorfahrten
verbraucht wird und das risiko für einen
bodenerosion verkleinert wird so ließen
sich europaweit jährlich 200 millionen
tonnen co2 immerhin im boden festhalten
das entspricht aber nicht einmal fünf
prozent der eu mission kann also alleine
nicht das thema retten mal ganz davon
abgesehen dass es wohl schwierig wird
millionen von bauern dazu zu bewegen auf
das pflügen zu verzichten aber immerhin
ein weg demnächst gibt es bei uns
übrigens ein längeres video zur zukunft
der landwirtschaft die könnte nämlich
schon bald ganz anders genannt werden
kleiner spoiler das dann in meinem buch
per aufzug in den weltraum ab oktober in
jeder guten buchhandlung neben den
methoden an land und in der luft kann
auch im wasser co2 gebunden werden
phytoplankton das sind winzige algen
können immer mehr große mengen an
kohlendioxid in sauerstoff umwandeln
nimmt man diese kleinen lebewesen in
bestimmten regionen mit eisensulfat
partikeln kann man ihr wachstum und
damit ihre umwandlungsquote erhöhen
nach dem absterben sinken die alten mit
den abbauprodukten in die tiefe der
gebundene kohlenstoff würde also auch
nicht so schnell zurück an die
atmosphäre gelangen das ist bislang aber
nur die theorie denn bisher konnte kein
experiment die deutliche steigerung der
co2 speicherung nachweisen außerdem sind
die auswirkungen auf die ökosysteme nur
schwer vorherzusagen also einige der
technologien stehen noch am anfang ihrer
entwicklung und sind bisher schnell an
ihre grenzen gestoßen es ist absehbar
dass es am ende vermutlich nicht die
eine methode sein wird mit der das klima
ziel erreicht werden kann sondern eine
kombination aus mehreren technologien
und natürlichen arten der co2
abscheidung aber dass wir ohne solche
lösungen gar nicht mehr auskommen meint
auch die expertin sabine fuß die
klimaforscherin des mercator research
institute
global kommen sind climate change die
auch als professorin an der berliner
humboldt-universität lehrt war leid
autorin für den sonderbericht des
weltklimarats zu 1,5 grad grenze sie
sagt zitat wir haben kein einziges
szenario gefunden die erwärmung auf 1,5
grad zu begrenzen ohne co2 aus der
atmosphäre zu entfernen sie betont um
wenigstens das 2 grad ziel zu erreichen
zitat müsste es nun eine abrupte
kehrtwende und deutliche veränderung
unseres lebensstils geben je länger wir
damit warten desto abhängiger machen wir
uns von co2 entnahme technologien oliver
geben der autor der aktuellen studie hat
eine noch schlechtere prognose zitat wir
werden das verbleibende co2 budget
überziehen für 1,5 grad und später wohl
auch für zwei grad und danach werden wir
immer noch treibhausgase emittieren
dann gibt es nur einen weg die
klimaziele zu erreichen das co2 wieder
herauszuholen negative emotionen
scheinen also der einzige weg aus der
klimakrise zu sein und sie werden mit
sicherheit noch für diskussionen
innerhalb der eu sorgen
da gibt es schließlich klimavorreiter
und nachzügler unter den
mitgliedsstaaten wenn zum beispiel polen
das immer noch auf fossile energieträger
setzt eingeräumt wird mit seinen
emissionen bis 2050 noch über der null
linie zu liegen dann müssten andere
staaten wie deutschland frankreich oder
schweden der atmosphäre mehr co2
entnehmen als sie selbst noch an
treibhausgasen ausstoßen um das
auszugleichen
da sind konflikte vorprogrammiert in den
meisten ländern gibt es noch nicht mal
eine strategie für den systematischen
aufbau von co2 entnahme technologien nur
frankreich bildet eine ausnahme und hat
zumindest schon angekündigt solche
technologien einzusetzen hierzulande in
deutschland gibt es sogar massive
widerstände gegen die abtrennung und
speicherung von co2 unter der
erdoberfläche entsprechende entscheidung
des bundesrats scheinen eine dauerhafte
treibhausgas neutralität unmöglich zu
machen nun corona hat der politiker
jetzt einige entscheidungen aus der hand
genommen
der flugverkehr ist nahezu zum erliegen
gekommen es gibt insgesamt weniger
geschäftsreisen videokonferenzen gehen
nämlich auch ziemlich gut und darin sehe
ich eine riesige perspektive
wahrscheinlich ist dieser weg jetzt auch
unausweichlich wenn wir
diese technologien jetzt entwickeln um
das klima zu beeinflussen dann lernen
wir erstens wie wir zum beispiel den
mars bewohnbar machen können aber auch
wie hier auf der erde auf natürliche
klimaveränderungen reagiert werden kann
die unsere existenz bedrohen der
ausbruch eines super vulkans würde dann
vielleicht seinen schrecken verlieren
und wir könnten einen anschließenden
vulkan winter verhindern
wir bilden zukunft die
bildungsinitiative vom freitag futures
ich war dort auf dem kanal zu gast also
anklicken und das video anschauen warum
wir auf die wissenschaft hören müssen
und freies for future hier auf youtube
unbedingt abonnieren bis dann bleibt
dran